bonjour je suis Laurent Berger je vais
commenter les archives de
Lina bonjour Laurent Berger bonjour vous
êtes ancien secrétaire général de la
CFDT c'est pas une surprise avec vous
nous allons nous pencher sur le travail
le travail d'hier le travail
d'aujourd'hui le travail de demain aussi
et on commence avec les trendes
glorieuses écoutz comment des enfants
imaginaient le futur du travail à
l'époque l'émission s'appelle le monde
de demain elle passait sur la RTF en
1962 comment est-ce que ça marcher la
vie tu auras un patron ou il y aura pas
de patron ou quoi il a pas de patron pas
de patron ça sera toi le patron ou bien
non quand même pas il y aura des patrons
puis des ouvriers ça c'est obligé comme
toujoursou et toi qu'est-ce que tu seras
làdedans je serai un P ouvrier comme
comme maintenant pourquoi un pauvre
ouvrier pour voir comment pour apprendre
tout ça est-ce que est-ce qu'il y a des
patrons pour toi dans Oh non j'aime pas
j'aime pas les patrons j' tout le
c'est que il y aura plus de patron et
moins d'ouvriersant donné que tout fera
automatiquement que tu veux faire
dansavenir je
méciciire
Industri moi je voudratre
architect de l' j're
caméraman
historien comment sera ton
métier000
ça sera toutes les machines qui font
tout al qu'est-ce que tu feras si les
marteaux marchent tout seul je je
regarderai les machines je les réglerai
on demanderait aujourd'hui à à des g à
des enfants ou à des jeunes de dire quel
métier dans dans 40 ans parce que cétait
40 ans il serait sans doute beaucoup
plus normal de le faire parce que les
évolutions sont tellement forte au
niveau technologique on a aussi de
nouvell nouvelles arrivées avec pas
simplement la robotisation com VO mais
la la la la l'intelligence artificielle
que ça va bouleverser y compris les
métiers et on sait tous que la grande
majorité des métiers de demain n'existe
pas aujourd'hui et justement comment
l'intelligence artificielle va
bouleverser le le monde du travail de la
même manière que c'était le cas pour la
robotisation la robotisation a été aussi
un bienfait pour nombre de travailleurs
moi mon père il était soudeur quand vous
avez des robots des machines qui peuvent
faire des des travaux qui étaient des
travaux difficiles et qu'il font avec
moins de pénibilité pour les les
travailleurs et travailleuse c'est pas
une mauvaise chose et et on sait tous
que ça fait bouger les métiers plus que
ça en supprime ça en supprime dans
certaines activités mais ça ça rajoute
pour pour d'autres ce qu'il faut
travailler c'est l'intelligence
artificielle éthique responsable comment
on va faire en sorte que ça ça ne
méprise pas le travailleur comme on a
essayé de le faire avec dans dans
l'action syndicale avec la robotisation
par exemple mais que ça ça son rôle soit
soit un rôle d'aide à la réalisation
d'une tâche d'un bien d'un service mais
pas de déshumaniser les enfants qu'on
vient d'entendre n'avaient pas tout
prévu ils n'avaient pas prévu ces petits
jobs précaires avec des patrons
lointains et invisible écoutez comment
Nabil décrivait son métier de coursier
face au caméras d'envoyer spécial en
1995 c'est un boulot de merde mais de
nos jours un boulot comme le mien j'ai
22 ans je gagne 8000 balles j'en
trouverai aucun j'en trouverai aucun
c'est sûr et certain bon en roulant on
réfléchit beaucoup on est comme je suis
tout seul toute la journée j'arrête pas
de réfléchir et de penser à tout et à
rien et des fois je me disais en fin de
compte les les sont comme nous
quoi elles sont sur le trottoir elles
sont toute la journée en train
d'attendre des clients comme nous on a
toute la journée dans Paris avec le bip
et on attend que ça sonne pour qu' a une
course et plus elles font de clients
plus elles font de de dooseil on a
affaire aujourd'hui à à à des
travailleurs dont on dit qu'ils sont
entre guillemets indépendants qui sont
fortement dépendants économiquement et
qui sont les nouveaux précaires les
nouveaux soutiers de notre société alors
avec une responsabilité très forte des
plateformes et de la capacité à les
réguler et à réguler cette relation de
travail en terme de rémunération de
conditions de travail et cetera c'est
vrai pour les livreurs puis une
responsabilité de la société vous saz
moi je suis frappé de deux choses c'est
quand euh en pleine inondation comme on
l'a vu dire on est capable de demander à
un livreur de vous emmener à manger ou
de vous emmener votre plaquette de
beurre ou quand vous êtes derrière un
camion de quelqu'un qui livre vous
faites du vélo à Paris ou ailleurs où
vous êtes en automobile et vous
cllaxonnez comme un malade vous râz vous
n'êtes pas dans cette espèce d'empathie
nécessaire à ces travailleurs là moi qui
vit à Paris voir C ces jeunes femmes et
hommes souvent des hommes d'ailleurs au
pied de leur vélo à attendre la commande
et et et toujours dans une forme de de
de de pression mais aussi de mépris
c'est c'est insupportable un autre
problème que ces enfants des Trente
Glorieuses n'ont pas vu venir le chômage
le chômage qui va faire des ravages dans
toutes les générations le témoignage
familial qui vient a été diffusé sur l'
RF en 196
JAC est-ce que tu as du travail en ce
moment non je
travail tu as déjà travaillé ouais comme
quoi
manutentionnaire là je travaille plus
j'avais juste un contrat de mois à faire
part où on va on va nous écrire on va
nous écrire nous écr Frid j'étais à
Green 2 j'ai rempli une
F dit que c'était complet après ils en
demandent on va voir ils disent que
c'est encore complet mais je me suis
laissé dire monsieur moi à cor la
semaine dernière et je suis le père DEC
j'aurais 40 ans au mois de juin que
j'étais trop
vieux alors Monsieur il faudrait savoir
si à 40 ans nous sommes trop vieux et a
à peine 17 ans 17 ans au mois de mai mon
fils est trop jeune cette période là
c'est c'est un
peu la mienne c'estd que c'est le poids
du chômage de masse a fait qu'on a
baissé de vigilance sur la question du
travail on pourrait y revenir mais
pourquoi on est mauvais tout simplement
parce que euh on on a a il y a un
phénomène de vision de de productivité
du rapport à ce qu'elle travaille le
travail c'est pas simplement une donnée
économique c'est pas simplement une
force productive le travail c'est aussi
de de de la compétence acquise et cetera
et euh il y a une part des entreprises
qui notamment du fait du chômage de
masse se sont dit bah on va jouer
simplement sur les phénomènes de
productivité et voilà présupposant
présupposant qu'un jeune é pas assez
expérimenté et qu'un vieux était trop
cher ou trop pusé euh et moins productif
euh il y a il y a cette réalité là la
deuxième c'est que on a un rapport au
travail qui est qui est biaisé notamment
sur la fin de carrière c'estd que ce
sentiment que la seule aspiration ce
serait de partir c'est pas une c'est pas
une réalité qu'on puisse pas se former
euh qu'on puisse pas se former après 50
ans ou 55 ans ce qui est pas une réalité
non plus et cetera donc on est mauvais
là-dessus et sur l'emploi des jeunes on
est mauvais parce que on n pas et on
n'est pas mauvais pour tous les jeunes
en vrai on est mauvais pour les jeunes
plutôt peu ou pas ou pas qualifiés tout
simplement parce que on n'a pas
construit les processus d'intégration
dans le monde du travail qui qui vont
bien et moi j'ai été conseiller en
insertion professionnelle je je peux
témoigner que tout tout tout toute
personne qui est employable il y a pas
il y a personne qui est inemployable il
y a tout un tas d'expériences
aujourd'hui qui le montre comme
territoire zéro chômeur et cetera je
suis sûr que ce jeune il irait
aujourd'hui à grrig 2 je sais pas
j'imagine que c'est un centre commercial
ou une plateforme de ce type sans doute
que ce serait un peu moins compliqué ça
veut pas dire que ce serait moins
précaire et pour les seigneors est-ce
que il y a pas aussi une question
euh de culture de de rapport de la
société à ces seiors
oui évidemment alors là c'était 40 ans
pour le le père de Jacques aujourd'hui à
partir de 45 ans on est senior ce qui
est quand même un truc de dingue en même
temps on allonge les carrières je crois
que c'est quand même lié à à la
productivité au supposés coût au fait
que on est moins agile pour se pour pour
évoluer professionnellement et et il y a
un espèce de moi il y a une
schizophrénie patronale qui est en gros
il faut travailler plus longtemps tout
le monde mais dès qu'on peut avoir
l'occasion de de sortir des seniors on
le fait euh et je crois que là il faut
pointer la responsabilité objectivement
des employeurs alors le chômage en
France a aussi été la conséquence des
délocalisations successives et des plans
sociaux une des solutions invoquées a
été de demander au salariés de changer
d'emploi et de territoire d'être
toujours plus mobile écouter un ouvrier
témoigner en
1972 peut-on s'attacher à
l'enfer pour ces hommes leurs peines
leur sueur leur effort se confondent
avec leur vie comme le lière l'homme
s'enracine partout j'aime mon métier
parce que je pense que mon métier c'est
un métier
noble faire de l'acier c'est beau pour
celà qui connaît on n'est pas des
aventuristes nous Laurin on est
attaché pourquoi parce que rien que les
deux dernières guerres mondiales on
s'est battu pour la laorine puis tout
d'un coup il faudrait partir pourquoi au
nom d'une économie au nom de gens des
techniciens des technocrates qui
décident comme ça au bout de 10 ans dire
bon bah là il faut partir maintenant
d'abord vous voyez le commentaire du
journaliste c'est des hommes c'est
l'enfer et et le travailleur derrière il
dit je suis fier de mon métier
c'estàdire qu'il faut jamais considérer
le travail des autres à la place de
d'eux-même ça veut pas dire qu'il est
pas difficile moi j'en connais je suis
je suis allé dans des dans dans la
sidérurgie je c'est évidemment des
conditions de travail difficiles mais la
fierté ouvrière c'est quelque chose de
fondamental la fierté des ouvriers vous
l'avez bien connu vous avec votre père
qui était euh soudeur sur les chantiers
de l'Atlantique ouais ouais moi je je je
suis encore et je suis encore très
attaché à ça très attaché à la fierté
des ouvriers vous savez je je considère
que c'est aussi la fierté euh du du du
du travailleur d'aujourd'hui euh qui euh
qui est pas forcément ouvrier ou sens où
on l'entendait c'estàd que moi ce qui me
frappe c'est que l'enquête qu'on avait
menée en 2017 elle montre que les
travailleurs et travailleuses ils sont
fiers de leur de leur métier la plupart
du temps ce qu'il dit c'est qu'on veut
on veut le faire dans de bonnes
conditions et moi oui j'ai été élevé
dans cette culture là j'ai allaé
chercher mon père à la sortie du bus
qu'il ramenait les chantiers au bout de
au bout de la rue et et il nous
racontait sa journée où o il nous
racontait la nature parce qu' il adorait
la nature et il était fier il était fier
il il était ouvrier soudeur enfin
d'abord manutentionnaire puis soudeur et
c'était c'était pas un ouvrier qualifié
mais c'était quand on voyait le pquebo
sortir ou le le métanier sortir on était
fier parce qu'il y avait participé donc
sur la question de la mobilité
géographique de changement de métier de
changement de métier déjà c'est
compliqué même si ça c'est aussi un
phénomène générationnel moi je suis
d'une génération où quand j'ai commencé
par le chômage on disait de toute façon
faut vous habituer à pas faire comme vos
pères qui travaillaient toute leur vie
dans la même entreprise euh faudra
bouger mais là la mobilité géographique
ça marche pas pour les ouvriers c'est
c'est il faut comprendre ça on est
attaché qu'est-ce qui fait qu'on est
attaché à son travail c'est évidemment
là où on vit là où qui nous permet de de
de de s'émanciper de gagner de gagner sa
vie et puis ce qui ce qui fait la vie
des uns et des autres c'est de la
solidarité de quartier lorsqu'il y a un
problème ben de de de de pouvoir se
confier les enfants quand vous avez
votre pavillon qui vaut plus rien parce
que tout casse la figure à côté si on
vous dit il faut vendre votre pavillon
et aller dans une zone plus dynamique
d'abord vous vous perdez toute cette
solidarité
territoriale toute votre ancrage toute
votre histoire et cetera et deuxièmement
vous vous avez un une difficulté à le
faire et compris économiquement qui qui
est énorme donc ça pas été suffisamment
pensé et c'est vrai que c'est vécu et
c'est c'est vécu comme étant une
approche technocratique ce que n'est pas
ce que c'est pas forcément enfin c'est
mais mais c'est en tout cas c'est
déconnecté d'une certaine réalité alors
la violence dans le monde du travail
elle a elle a toujours existé et puis
elle a elle a aussi été la conséquence
des des des localisations des plans
sociaux du chômage mais cette violence
elle a pris des formes différentes au
fil des années on va regarder un exemple
très représentatif rappelez-vous Air
France en
2015 des images qui provoquent un
malaise elles illustrent la violence des
turbulences qui secouent Air France cet
homme c'est le directeur des ressources
humaines pris à parti par des salariés
il quitte les lieux se fait pousser
arracher sa chemise il finira par
escalader la
Pouru la foule en
colère tous ces dirigants ét en comité
central d'entreprise quelques minutes
plus tôt quand un groupe de manifestants
fait irruption dans la
Réunion ils sont échaudés par les
annonces de la direction elle vient de
confirmer ce qu'il
[Musique]
craign interrompu tous quitte le
bâtiment sur ce parvie la situation
dégénère c'est la première fois que la
compagnie officialise de poss possible
licenciement sec là c'est très grave ce
style d'image ça fait pas du bien au
syndicalisme il y a le droit d'envahir
une salle de de de de réunion et cetera
il y a pas le droit de s'en prendre à
des individus il y a pas le droit c'est
pas pas dans cette situation là ils
étaient pas menaçants ils ont pas menacé
les gens qui leur ont arraché la chemise
quand à on est chez nous on est chez
nous moi je me méfie beaucoup de ces
parolesl on les entend ailleurs et ell
me choque aussi le monde du travail
c'est quoi c'est un des des des des
conflits d'intérêts des conflits de
logique entre l'employeur et les
salariés ça se ça ça se règle évidemment
par de la la confrontation c'est pas
l'endroit où il y a le moins de dialogue
social et il y a le moins Air France et
où il y a moins de capacité dans les
instances à se faire entendre ça veut
pas dire qu'il y a pas de manifestation
à mener de grève et cetera c'est pareil
que dans la société si on n'arrive pas
par la voie de la la confrontation des
intérêts divergents à faire sortir des
compromis euh on va vers des actions
comme ça et là je peut-être qu'il y
avait une responsabilité sûrement qu' y
avait une responsabité ité de la
direction d'Air France de la façon dont
il menait cette activité là ce plan
social à l'époque et j'ai pas d'état
d'AM là-dessus mais ça ne justifie pas
ça on a souvent entendu pendant les
manifestations des gilets jaunes que les
gilets jaunes ne souhaitent pas se
tourner vers les syndicats parce qu'ils
se sentaient pas représentés il
considérer que ça servait à rien comment
vous vous avez vécu cette cette période
B
d'abord la crise des gilets jaunes c'est
une crise qui est une crise de
d'invisibilité le phénomène de quand on
est être soignant de pas pouvoir être
soignant de pas pouvoir viivre deement
de son travail ben c'est une réalité
quand on est livreur de sentiment ou
routier ben le sentiment de pas être
respecté parce qu'on n pas payé à juste
à juste niveau de de de ce qu'on fait
c'est une réalité ça cette crise des
gilets jaunes elle fini comment
excusez-moi de vous le dire mais en en
jus de boudin qui a pu dire on a obtenu
ça personne parce que c'est jamais
évidemment assez parce que c'est faire
une organisation syndicale en disant bah
on a au moins cranté des choses et puis
est-ce que ça a apaisé démocratiquement
le pays non ça a pas apaisé quelle est
la force du contrat dans une société ou
dans une entreprise quand vous signez un
accord c'est que vous engagez les partis
et qu'aujourd'hui on a plus cette
culture du compromis et du contrat dans
notre société alors on va évoquer
maintenant un autre problème mondial
cette fois qui perdure dans le monde du
travail en
1968 déjà l'émission les femmes aussi se
pencher sur les inégalités salariales
entre les hommes et les femmes quand
avez-vous passé votre cap en l'année 66
c'est de quoi mécanique
générale et vous Michelot CP en 1966 CP
de stenodactilo où travaillez-vous Henri
aux établissements la rougeoubert à
Saint-Michel et vous Michel
établissement la rochbert à Saint-Michel
combien vous gagnez par mois h 66000
francs par
mois et vous Michel combien vous gagnez
55000 c'est c'est ça n'a pas bougé c'est
parce qu'on fait vivre un scandale parce
que même dans les entreprises où les
fonctions sont les mêmes trop souvent on
a des salaires qui sont plus faits pour
les il y a les lois la loi elle interdit
ça il y a des accords il y a des indexes
pour mesurer les inégalités ça ne bouge
pas assez vite donc à un moment donné il
faut qu'il y ait des sanctions il faut
qu'il y ait des sanctions pour les
entreprises c'est comme ça qu'on
arrivera à ce qu'il y ait des plans de
retour à un équilibre qui n'a jamais
existé d'ailleurs entre les les les
femmes et les hommes et là on a une
faillite collective ça veut pas dire que
chacun fait pas sa part essae pas de
faire sa part de boulot mais ça ne bouge
pas ça ne bouge pas suffisamment et ça
ne bouge pas aussi parce que y compris
dans la répartition des métiers on a
encore une une vision très genrée quand
vous regardez la part des jeunes filles
dans les métiers de l'innovation et
cetera elle est faible pourquoi parce
que il y a une forme de représentation
sociale que c'est plutôt des métiers
masculins ce qui est totalement
[Applaudissements]
idiot ma mère était une militante
féministe convaincue toute sa vie pas
que sur le terrain du travail d'ailleurs
j'en ai encore parlé récemment avec elle
ça continue de la
rendre la rendre extrêmement en colère
hommes ou femm certains métiers
n'attirent plus les Français écoutez ce
patron d'une entreprise de BTP en 1971
la main d'œuvre étrangère en grossissant
le nombre des travailleurs est donc un
facteur de production et de croissance
et bien souvent elle pâie une absence de
candidature pour certains emplois des
Français en fait nous sommes obligés
d'employer des étrangers car on
s'aperçoit que la main d'œuvre française
S adapte mal à notre travail et il faut
reconnaître que si cette mainœuvre
étrangère n'était pas en France on se
demande comment on fait nos travaux
c'est peut-être un problème de formation
professionnelle c'est peut-être un
problème de salaire toujours est-il
qu'en ce qui nous concerne en tous les
cas sur ce chantier les étrangers ont le
même salaire que les Français à
qualification égale c'est un témoignage
qui aurait pu être enregistré
aujourd'hui ouais on serait dans dans le
bâtiment et TP aussi on serait dans
l'hôtellerie restauration
euh si cétait enregistré aujourd'hui bah
d'abord ça montre que on a besoin des
travailleurs étrangers et que du coup il
faut lorsqu'il travaillent pouvoir les
régulariser euh et les considérer de la
même manière que n'importe quel
travailleur mais oui il y a des métiers
pour des questions de pénibilité qui qui
qui qui sont plus désertés
euh alors c'est dans le bâtiment il y a
eu beaucoup d'effort là il y a eu un
beaucoup de changement dans les ETP et
et le bâtiment depuis cette p iriode
notamment du fait de l'action syndicale
notamment sur les conditions de travail
sur les rémunérations aussi puis mais il
y a d'autres secteurs où notamment je
pense à secteur agricole ou au secteur
de la restauration ù les conditions à la
fois salariales les conditions de
travail et et et plus largement des
conditions d'exercice des métiers font
que bien sûr on a on a difficulté de
recrutement et qui dit difficultés de
recrutement dit dit parfois bah pour
pour les employeurs il faut il faut bien
faire
tourner la machine et que c'est souvent
des travailleurs issus de de de de
l'immigration des travailleurs étrangers
et là et c'est là où il faut qu'on
arrête ces débats à la con excusez-moi
de le dire comme ça de la période où on
considérerait que que c'est que c'est un
problème c'est sans doute une partie de
la solution à une seule condition c'est
qu'on les régularise un autre aspect du
travail qui ne date pas d'hier et qui
revient particulièrement au centre des
préoccupations aujourd'hui le bien-être
regardez ce reportage qui passait sur l'
RTF en 1974
8 heur de travail d'affilé ou en deux
fois à l'usine comme au bureau assis ou
debout peuvent fatiguer certaines
parties du corps et par contrecoup
enquyoser le
[Musique]
reste une décontraction est alors
nécessaire certaines usines de notre
région ont résolu le problème et ce
grâce à une gymnastique particulière
appelée gymnastique de
pause cette gymnastique a pour effet de
couper le travail de délacer pendant
quelques minutes ouvrières et
employés qui n'ont que quelques mètres à
faire pour suivre le cours en tenu de
travail d'où pas de perte de
temps le travail c'est un facteur
d'émancipation c'est un facteur de
réalisation de reconnaissance puis c'est
aussi d'abord une une forme d'impact sur
sa situation physique ou sa situation
psychique et l'idée c'est pas de dire il
faut pas qu'il y a d'impact sur physique
c'est qu'il faut pas que ça le dégrade
qui est le meilleur expert du travail
les travailleurs qui est le meilleur de
la tâche à de la façon dont on peut
réaliser la tâche en étant le moins
agressif possible à l'écart de son corps
ou de son ou de son ou de son esprit les
travailleurs et partout on a développé
du dialogue professionnel c'est-à-dire
cette capacité des salariés à dire bah
voilà on pourrait faire bouger mon
boulot de telle ou telle manière et bien
partout on a amélioré le le le le le la
qualité de vie au travail et le
sentiment de reconnaissance en fait vous
êtes en train de dire que un baby foot
ça sert à rien si le salarié est pas
écouté s'il y a pas un management qui
moi j'adore le Baby fooot mais je le
fais avec mes potes dans les bars mais
ça serait si c'est ça qui améliore les
conditions de travail alors ça veut pas
dire qu' faut pas qu'il y en ait voilà
c'est ça veut pas dire qu'il faut pas
qu'il y ait des des des des événements
de convivialité et cetera mais si vous
allez jouer au babyfoot et vous
retournez vous avez le sentiment que la
le le le votre poste de travail il est
pas aménagé pour vous il respecte pas
votre intégrité physique vous pouvez
retourner au Baby fooot et ça sera la
même chose après donc non il faut être
il faut être sérieux et si plutôt que de
vouloir être heureux au travail il
fallait être heureux sans travailler je
laisse la parole à George mustouaki qui
s'exprimait sur la paresse dans
aujourd'hui la vie en 1982 la paresse
c'est un régulateur je veux dire qui qui
qui compense notre hystérie laborieuse
et donc répond à des besoins du corps
oui il il y a aussi le fait que c'est
une idéologie c'est c'est une
proposition philosophique de si on
détermine la paresse comme étant une
vertu et non pas un péché véniel ou
mortel on on cherche ces aspects
positifs ces aspects créatifs ces
aspects disons d'aspiration au bien-être
et au bonheur au moment où l'Europe
industrialisé découvrait le le travail
le travail industrialisé c'est-à-dire
particulièrement
oppressif euh Paul lafarg à la Chambre
des députés a proposé un droit à la
paresse qui rejoint des aspirations qu'
qu'on a trouvé par la suite aussi bien
dans les
mouvements d'après-guerre dans les
mouvements IPI dans les mouvements
écologistes c'est le droit à s'amuser un
peu dans cette vie et ne pas penser à
consommer à produire exclusivement
ouais j'aime beaucoup George mustouaki
comme artiste mais c'est une vision un
peu un peu un peu du vu de côté quoi
d'ailleurs il a sûrement beaucoup
travaillé lui-même pour produire autant
de de de jolis morceaux et de et de
poésie le droit à la paraisse moi je
suis j'adore ça être paresseux mais ça
m'empêche pas de travailler il y a une
vision parfois à à gauche du travail qui
serait vu que comme un phénomène
d'oppression il le dit c'est pas du tout
concordant avec ce que pensent les
travailleurs et travailleuses ce qu'il
faut c'est parler de du temps de travail
parler de l'articulation entre la vie
personnelle et la vie professionnelle de
la reconnaissance au travail mais il y a
aucune gauche qui prospérera pas moi je
me suis opposé dans un débat à Madame
Rousseau qui m'expliquait que le
l'objectif était de de de de pas
travailler pour nombre de gens c'est pas
vrai vous avez connu le chômage moi je
l'ai connu le chômage c'est le sentiment
d'inutilité vous avez le sentiment de
d'être laissé de côté euh et donc l'idée
c'est pas de travailler à outrance c'est
pas que le travail Abî c'est pas que le
travail au Pr mais c'est l'idée que le
travail peut émanciper et ça si des
forces de gauche oublient cette cette
cette histoire ir là ils vont laisser
les travailleurs au mains d'autres et
c'est déjà le cas on va parler
maintenant d'une d'une utopie qui a qui
a marqué un conflit social qui a marqué
l'histoire et l'imaginaire du du travail
dans les années 70 qui vous a marqué
vous aussi un conflit dans lequel la
CFDT a joué un rôle majeur écoutter
parler des anciens ouvriers de Lip pour
la première fois dans l'histoire du
mouvement ouvrier en France les
travailleurs d'une entreprise se sont
payés eux-mêmes à Besançon les salariés
de Lip ont touché leur paye du mois de
juin intégr em salaire qu'ils ont
prélevé sur le produit de la vente des
mondes cela représente environ 2
millions de francs dès 15h30 900
personnes environ se sont présentés au
guichet installés dans les locaux de la
direction émotion pour les uns
satisfaction pour les autres
l'impression est difficile à saisir
c'est dit pour tous ce jour est
historique s continue vraiment à ne plus
nous payer puisquil devait nous payer 12
jours ils l'ont pas fait et ben on
continuera comme ça tant qu'il le faudra
mais on aura notre argent du moment
qu'on est à l'usine et qu'on travaille
non avant j'avais jamais imaginé une
chose pareille est-ce que ça vous semble
illégal ou est-ce que ça vous semble
normal et bien non ça me semble pas
illégal pas du
tout du fait que dans le fond l'usine
c'est nous les
ouvriers nous avons travailler pour pour
avoir notre peuille non nous ne sommes
pas des voleurs d'ailleurs tout le monde
peut venir ici visiter il y a pas de vol
il y a justement une très organisée très
populaire c'est émouvant moi j'avais à
peu près 10 ans enfin un peu moins et il
était hors de question à la maison que
quelqu'un a une montre pour son
10eersaire ou autre qu' soit pas une
Lipe euh mais j'ai j'ai j'ai grandi au
moment de ce conflit avec des parents
qui qui animer des collectifs pour les
soutenir et cetera donc le le voilà ça
c'est ça me rappelle ça et il se trouve
que la montre que je porte c'est une
montre où c'est écrit lip et c'est un
hasard on l'a pas travaillé ensemble
hein euh c'est écrit on produit on vend
on se pie et justement est-ce que ça a
été un tournant dans l'histoire des
luttes syndicales dans la mesure où ça a
quelque part un peu signé la la fin des
rêves et des des utopies concernant le
travail non il y a c'est pas la fin des
rêves et des utopies c'est moi je je je
je B un pe cette particularité j'ai
jamais cru au grand soir j'ai cru jamais
cru et pourtant je suis un militant
toute ma vie depuis 14 j'ai 14 ans j'ai
je continue de l'être différemment j'ai
jamais cru que tout d'un coup on
réglerait tous les problèmes c'est
d'abord c'est une le de dignité c'est
fondamental la dignité quand on est de
milieu populaire ou de milieu ouvrier de
de de de de vouloir être respecté c'est
c'est c'est un vrai beau modèle qui
s'est qu' a vécu un petit moment euh qui
s'est éteint comme chacun sait mais qui
a quand même montré qu'il y avait une
voix et ça existe cette voix elle
continue aujourd'hui il il y a des
coopératives ouvrièr il y a des
coopératives il a il y a il y a des il y
a des structurations des modèles
d'entreprise qui sont beaucoup plus
ocratique le modèle classique qui
travaille aujourd'hui moi j'ai
aujourd'hui je suis dans une entreprise
mutualiste qui où il y a une gouvernance
qui se qui est pas une gouvernance
d'actionnariale qui est une gouvernance
des sociétaires c'est des modèles donc
qui un autre modèle d'économie peut
exister et c'était un peu ça a été un
peu les les prémisses si vous regardez
tous ceux qui se sont battus depuis des
années des décennies des centaines
d'années et cetera pour le droit à la
dignité pour le droit des travailleurs
et cetera vous pouvez vous dire vu
aujourd'hui comment ça se passe
finalement est-ce que tout ça a servi
mais évidemment que ça a servi ça a
servi euh et euh et que ça reste pour
moi un combat emblématique Laurent
Berger nous allons nous intéresser
maintenant à un conflit beaucoup plus
récent écouter ces militants
syndicalistes s'en prendre à la CFDT en
2020 un CFDT c'est toujours pareil c'est
toujours la même chose mais ça on le
savait depuis le début de toute façon
qu'à partir du moment où il y aurait une
petite proposition qui sortirait du
mouvement il y a un problème de un
problème d'écoute entre la base et euh
la base et la tête et ça je le regrette
je le regrette et même certains le
ressentent comme une trahison la
détermination n'a jamais été aussi
grande écoutez-mi j'ai perdu 40 jours de
grève il est hors de question que je
reprenne le travail pourquoi pour un
faux compromis qui s'apparente plus à
une compromission qu'un compromis vous
savez quand vous êtes responsable
syndical faut fautut faut être basé faut
être convaincu sur ces valeurs faut
avoir un certain nombre de principes et
puis il faut porter les propositions
collectives de la CFDT ça m'a jamais
fait trembler on a on est dans un pays
qui accuse de compromission à chaque
fois qu'on passe un compromis il y a une
expression qui à court chez nous c'est
nos trahisons d'aujourd'hui sont leur
sont leurs acquis de
demain et c'est une réalité et
aujourd'hui la CFDT est devenue la
première organisation syndicale parce
qu'on a jamais menti au travailleurs
parce qu'on ne ment jamais au
travailleurs et on les emmène jamais
dans le mur on va passer à la dernière
archive celle d'un président avec lequel
le courant n'est jamais passé il y a eu
l'épisode grec je ne céderai
rien ni au fénéant ni au cyniqu ni aux
extrêmes un peu avant le rouain les
Françaises et les Français détestent les
réformes il faut dorénavant ajouter à la
liste cette phrase du président de la
République prononcée hier au Danemark ce
qui est ici possible est lié à une
culture un peuple marqué par son
histoire et ce peuple luthérien qui a
vécu les transformations des dernières
décennies n'est pas exactement le
Gaulois réfractaire au changement
mais encore que je crois que euh que les
salariés français ils sont productive je
crois que que les réformes sont
possibles mais je crois que pour ça faut
avoir une volonté de dialogue et que la
volonté de dialogue c'est des deux côtés
et personne vous voyez l'archive
précédente c'était la CFDT veut trop
discuter était une traître et puis là
c'est euh personne veut discuter bah on
a toujours voulu discuter moi j'ai
toujours été ouvert à la discussion à la
négociation au compromis même mais il
faut que ce soit des deux côtés alors
c'est le moment pour moi d'arrêter de
vous poser des questions c'est vous qui
allez choisir le journaliste qui va vous
poser la dernière entre Anne Saint-Clair
Henry Chapier Christine auocrin et
Jean-Louis servant schrebert Anne
Saint-Clair votre enfance ça demeure
quelque chose de préservé de où vous
étiez un être pur tout en
potentialité moi mon enfance c'est celle
d'un enfant plutôt timide et R un peu le
plus fragile de la fraterie on était
quatre dans une famille ouvrière modeste
mais extrêmement extrêmement aimante
voilà il y a y a une chanson qui dit nul
ne guérit de son enfance moi j'ai pas
besoin d'en guérir parce que j'ai j'ai
eu cette chance de grandir dans une
famille aimante et une famille engagée
ma double filiation elle est elle est
cette famille elle est cet ancrage cette
fierté ouvrière don j'ai parler de les
piquets de grève mais aussi les manifes
mais aussi les
sorties dans la nature et cetera mon
autre filiation c'est l'éducation
populaire c'est-à-dire que on milite et
on apprend les uns avec les autres et on
progresse les uns avec les autres donc
voilà ouais je je la pureté je sais pas
ce que c'est mais en tout cas j'ai je
crois que ça m'a beaucoup structuré
merci beaucoup Laurent Berger merci à
[Musique]
vous